John Wick chapter 4 isn't over by the
time the credits start rolling in fact
the post-credits scene might just hint
toward the future of the franchise
spoilers for John Wick 4. after four
films five dogs and a handful of high
table seats being vacated the Baba Yaga
finally bit the dust in John Wick
chapter 4. parking himself on the stone
steps all bloodied and beaten he calls
out his wife's name and seemingly
shuffles off this Mortal coil but while
the world may have lost John Wick the
Assassin's Network and the Allies or
enemies inhabiting it are still in
business as are scores that desperately
need to be settled one such Feud that
spills over following Jon's
parisian-based payback is between Akira
and the former friend of kojis that
killed him Kane in fact their dispute is
so significant it got its own bit of
screen time in a post-credits scene of
John Wick chapter 4 marking a first for
the film series that we didn't expect
but what does this sliver of a showdown
imply for a franchise's future that as
far as we now know is without its
firearm loving frontman here is where
the series could go next what did you
think was
what did you expect huh did you really
think this day was never going to come
following the bloodbath at the
Continental Osaka which saw Kane cut
down Koji Akira swears revenge against
her father's killer and isn't seen again
for the rest of the film it's not like
Kane is Keen to do it of course given
that he's under orders to take Jon down
along with anyone else helping him for
fear of his own daughter being killed
should he fail to do so it is in the
post-credits scene that we finally see
Akira go in for the kill hoping to get
Blood for Blood until a swift cut to
Black stops us from witnessing the
outcome it's an unexpected extra to the
story not just because it follows the
climax of John Wick's Journey but
because it's teasing a spin-off that
isn't either of the two already
confirmed Ana de armas's ballerina and
the TV prequel show the Continental have
been well-known projects in development
for some time and we haven't caught a
glimpse of either so far with that in
mind hinting at another area for the
burgeoning franchise to expand with this
plotline is a welcome surprise for
starters it means more Tales to tell in
this world of markers trackers and
tailored bulletproof suits but also
given the character characters and story
involved this could end up being a John
Wick spin-off movie the franchise didn't
know it needed since the beginning John
Wick for the most part has been a lone
wolf only showing us one side of a story
and teaming up with other Gunslingers
for relatively brief scenes both in
Parabellum with Halle Berry and Lance
Reddick and in chapter 4 with Donnie Yen
interestingly these were highlights in
both films and a stylistic choice that
could be replicated in a future movie
with Donnie Yen and Rina sawayama in a
more detailed fashion not only could
this potential project tell a
complicated story that pits two
compelling characters against one
another but it could also see them
working together as a team when the dust
settles we know that Kane isn't a bad
guy and the actions taken against
Akira's family were to protect his own
this could be the murky Middle Ground
the potential enemies could meet on just
like Kane and Wick did leaving them to
unite and go after the high table the
powers that make this world as cruel and
cold-hearted as it is sure Marquis De
gramonte may be out of the picture but
when it comes to that mysterious
organized station that's a table that
has plenty more room to clear Akira
along with Kane could be the ones to do
it should they be successful from there
they could Branch off into their own
solo films expanding on a world that has
so much more potential and more
importantly so many more killer
contracts to be completed after all
we're still waiting to see if we ever
see Jason manzukas's Unforgettable
Tick-Tock man back on screen tick tock
[Music]